yeah my name is Yuri so i'll talk about
less decoding okay so let's see these
some subsets of the having space then we
define these least decoding radios with
least up to size l as maximum overall
radiuses okay so i will keep forgetting
to normalize by end but it's usually all
my radiuses and distances between 0 and
1 a so this is the maximum a racial are
over and such that a for every ball of
radius R his intersection with the code
is cardinality lesson l basically this
is just the condition which says a your
points the points of the code do not
concentrate anywhere a too much okay so
equivalently we can write this as 1 over
n minimum of radius of s ok button
instead of putting a slim put it was one
I need to put minus one where CM c c sub
i is just so this is just all
collections of points a size l plus 1
selected from the code right so a ok so
i'm not going to explain why a white
school to look at such objects but
geometric loads important is that you
can also think of so for this size 1
this is just a standard parking hard
sucking of hard spheres right so you
basically want to park many a balls of a
given radius inside your space and when
you go from l equals 1 to some larger L
instead of having this strict constraint
of balls never intersecting you just
relax this condition to saying ok so the
balls are allowed to intersect but
multiplicity of intersection should be
rebounded by L so there should not be
more than L guys on top of a any point
okay so what's the important fundamental
limit yes as always we defined
asymptotic fundamental limit to be lim
soap and goes to infinity right larger
please oh okay yeah i'll try rim soup as
n goes to infinity of 1 over n algorithm
of the maximum of the cardinality of all
codes who's a sorry this is them
finding this and this is just maximum of
tau l of see among all codes of rate are
okay so now we know this function for
Noel and the interesting question is a
okay so let me just summarize what is
known for l equals 1 a picture is as
follows okay so usually of course you
can also define the the inverse of this
function right distance and usually
that's how you draw it a for l equals 1
pair of bones gilbert rational bound and
the mrw bound then
people know this okay what's important
for me is that m rrw bound has the
following expression or in the region so
here so somewhere here it has the
following a closed-form formula one half
where delta LP of our is just one half
minus root but a 1 minus beta or what is
better well bat is formed by solving
over right here right and better run one
half okay huh so this is the situation
as nice lineal said yesterday and this
banana has stayed at this particular
width for 40 years okay so for this size
2 so when you go to this size 2 again
this oh yeah and then the interesting
thing is that i will keep calling in the
stock at this point where something hits
zero rate the plot can point a so the
talking point for listicles 2 is the
same it's one quarter again there is
gilbert or shaman bound proved by blinov
ski so i don't know roebling it and then
ok so then for 15 years starting from
1986 the best bound was due to Blue
Mosque and then in 1999 Schekman bargain
listen they improved this bound so they
currently hold the record for the a
upper bound for l equals 2 okay so for
all other lists sizes the situation is
still as in blue mostly 96
386 a picture is like this okay so
what's what's most astonishing to me is
that first of all for once you go from
least size 22 this size three the plot
can point actually moves so for example
for l equals three okay so the formula
for this point is all these minus ones
are plus minus one I don't remember but
roughly I remembered it for l equals
three it's five sixteenth so a right so
again so this is blinov ski gilberto
sheriff and the best bound before this
talk a was also blinov ski yay so this
was the sort of the situation and in the
stock what we will do is we will eat a
little piece of little banana a right so
this oh ok so a you can see I'm not
beating blue nosky uniformly unlike a BL
so abl guys were able to beat them
everywhere I only beat them in some way
in some region however I claim that I
mean I I so so the interesting
improvement is that is here because blue
no skis upper bound ok the below speed
lower bound always has slope 0 and the
nosc is upper bound haslope nonzero so
in the upper bound in the stock actually
has slope 0 so this settles the slope at
least and
talk ah yes at the blood kin point
that's right yes so maybe just as a sort
of this has no relation to my talk but I
just wanted to say that whenever the fur
I mean every time I think about the fact
that the plot can point from going to
from two to three actually increases I
think I mean I cannot just understand it
in my head because you see it tells you
that you can only park finitely many
plot can actually tells you can only
file pack finitely many spheres of
radius 1 half one-fourth plus epsilon
right but if you allow triple overlap
you can pack exponentially mini right so
this is always found astonishing and all
the second interesting thing is that
there is a Sergei behind in my first
year in grad school actually told me
there is a super you know he said
information there is so simple the
easiest bound is hemming bonds already
achieved and then so by random codes so
a indeed there is this Hamming bound 1
minus H of a cow right just sheer
packing bound and the interesting thing
is that basically this decoding allows
you to a this list decoding bounds they
all converge to a Hamming bound so you
basically list according makes you
information theoretic in some sense so
it makes you a conversion as L Kosygin
yes as all goes to infinity I think it's
1 over i'll actually the gap or 1 over l
square I don't know okay so on this talk
for all would L greater than 3 we prove
a bound tau L star are less than okay so
i'm going to i cannot put the expression
expression is complicated because but i
will just give you in some intuition and
so some a rough idea what it involves so
a so its maximum over final many numbers
and maximum all over one continuous
parameter of a certain closed form
function closed form expression sorry
0j and rate right and but there is a
corollary which I will actually try to
so which is it look a bit easier to
prove in particular I can state it so
for all rates less than certain
threshold tau L star of our is upper
bounded by g one of Delta L P one of our
okay where g one this is degree l
polynomial explicit i will i will give
you the formula in a little bit so i'm
going to talk about this corollary
mostly and this corollary also settles
the slope so you don't need to go to the
heart they're bound to settle the slope
okay so right so II so what's the let me
first to start with a very high level
overview
review the proof okay so we start with
the following idea view to Kauai and
linnea email 95 95 96 it's a fantastic
it's a fantastic two page paper which
basically created the avalanche of
results and in particular one of my
favorite results in the last 20 years
which is by Lytton a shriek Muhlenberg
who proves that this week a Gallagher
but lower bound on error exponent is
actually tight in a small range below
critical it's a it's an astonishing
complicated and strong result and
actually yeah we'll never ask even
Shannon Award winners in information
theory they never heard of this sounds I
it amazes me how this result could have
been skipped but it's a super and this
was a a basically
this progress okay so so okay so we
start with the cold so it's a collection
of points and the kal'ai-il NL what they
will tell us is they will tell us that
well somewhere in this space there must
exist a distinguished code word C 0 and
the sphere of certain radius Europe
radius 0 and and spheres I will denote
by s where this is size 0 and this is
exactly unfortunately they don't tell us
what the radio so that's here is this a
just it exists with what property well
with the property that there are
exponentially many code words on that
sphere so this is if you've heard about
this this is a just extraction of an
exponential component of a cold
distribution ok so then then the proof
proceeds by three reduction so first you
start with the number of code words em
right so this is roughly two to the N
are so then you apply Cal I lineal so
you get the sub-code let's c prime but
now it's it's on us here so it has some
structure right so now its head ok so
this is not much less it's
I'm so this is of some right 2 to the N
our prime okay so then you further
reduce this is Cal I linear reduction so
when you reduce c prime significantly by
doing allies basilica type trick and the
cardinality of this code book so this
code book used to you prove the code
book even more to extract even more
structure in in this in this code book
so this is going to be of some very
small rate to today an episode and then
finally in the final reduction is a
terrible reduction and so this is I mean
this is multiple logarithmic so like
this is some exponential towers here
involved because this is by Ramsey
theory so this is reduction to a some
very very small furthermore sub-code but
which has so much structure if I can
actually prove cool things about it so
this is a I mean again Bruno ski is idea
basically but somehow blue no ski
basically we derive the huge portion of
roms here is also a I just called it our
MC ok so for proving corollary this step
is not needed so let's assume that's why
hey ago I can probably be able to tell
you two something because I can skip
this step ok so right so let's start
with the some details so what is Cal I
lineal reduction ok so how do you prove
that I give you a code how do you prove
that there exists a point which is
surrounded by exponential many points a
certain distance so here's how they did
it they said well look those guys mclees
rather miss Ramsey and Welch we found a
collection of functions only only on the
hemming cube right parameterize by
continuous parameter beta so with what
properties so this is a functions acting
from that
having cube two reels what with the
following two properties first of all
they're fully transform is always no
negative and the second cool property is
that if you if you look at how does this
function behave it actually only depends
on the weight of X so the spherically
symmetric it's a time for you oh I see
okay sorry yeah I'm on record so I
cannot repeat my usual Cohen yeah yeah
my usual comment again I'm a fan of
chalk boards and I think they don't
expire right so they don't contribute to
the economy of waste ok so anyway so so
this have bet effects so how does it
look like well is this okay okay so yeah
so this have better of X actually only
depends on a on the weight of X and it
looks roughly like this so it's a really
strange function because it's very hard
to satisfy these two constraints
simultaneously you want positive Fourier
transform and you want it to be positive
up until some distance and then the
negative so this distance is actually
exactly they'll tell LP this distance is
one-half minus root better 1 minus beta
right okay and okay so how do you use
such a function well it's very simple
now if you manage to yeah so as I agree
with naughty this is a super mysterious
proof but it's very elementary to if you
just believe that okay somebody comes
and gives you such functions okay let me
just use it so how are you going to use
it you say okay why don't i compute
something like this right the inner
product so this is the indicator of a
code right so if you just express this
you just turn
and this becomes this expression right
on one hand and now so you can introduce
the following numbers you can rewrite
this as some of jay from 0 to n rightly
now 0 of the code times what times f of
j write the value of the function at j
times the weight distribution of the
code at distance j right what is a GF c
is just number of pairs distance j as
you just go over in the entire code and
count of this pairwise statistic okay so
so you get this expression but on the
other hand you can take fully transform
right and why plancha rail all right so
you get something like this and the
because I have bet is positive you can
just lower bounded by the value at zero
all right so you can just lower bound it
a right and the Fourier transform was
indicator of C at 0 is just the size of
the code so you get the okay so the mrw
estimate was to say okay if you have
minimum distance d cold right and if d
is somewhere land somewhere here right
then all the contributions here except
for the first term are negative right so
you can just write it like this so this
was the mrw contribution right so you
can write it like this and then just by
comparing these two sides you get the
upper bound that ok then the cold the
cardinality of the code should be a just
a F of 0 / f hat 0 0 right conveniently
here you are exactly 2 to the 1 and H of
beta so this is exactly what you get ok
Sokka line linea observed the following
thing so they said well yes so this is
if minimum distance of the code exceeds
this number right exceeds one-half minus
root beta 1 minus
this only holds here but they said okay
forget about this let's let's even take
let's even a drop this assumption
suppose it there are some values here
right well then there must exist but in
any case right in any case there must
exist some j let's call it as oxide 0
times n such that aj auxerre oh sorry aj
the weight distribution of the code is
lower bounded by ok a note of C F better
hat at zero normalized by a better at
this just tells you ok so there is God
exists one point like this so I spent so
much time on this instead of just
quoting result because in many so since
I i submitted this many reviewers asking
so can you explain why you have zero
slope and velocity has non zero slope so
in my opinion this is the part which
actually is the main contribution so
basically some positive semi-definite
pneus he is key ok so
wondering I mean are there just
impossible radio so ah yes buy the
digital principal doesn't well some of
them are some of them are negative right
so there's a so not sure what you just
saying there's a sphere with all right
mm-hmm Oh with the question is what's
the estimate on right of course you can
just apply I mean Eliza bustle it gives
you the same thing right but here this
is this is a sphere centered at the Cold
War so this is very important that this
is a sphere centered at the Cold War
just there's only impossible
oh you're talking about linear codes Oh
already okay Center it low know if it's
an okay centered anywhere better you're
impossible radii there's an X so one of
sub one radius has to have that
exponential I mm-hmm what does that give
the signal over here no of course not
hey okay so let's see so so you're
saying a so let's start with the let's
say linear code right and so yes you
have 10 look at all the spheres around
one of them a lot right it's a good
point so now I never thought about it
yeah so a
I mean this is of course a stronger
statement right it tells you that a on
average right on average if you center
on any point you get this maybe you're
right fine it's something better than GV
bounded some radius latest oh yes of
course yes right right but wait but
still he gets the rate he gets the whole
rate so this is a feeling something
weaker than that isn't there an
amplification lobster yeah so so what
yeah so what when got the saying is that
basically a the right here right it's
it's a little bit better than binomial
yeah but but he gets even better so
let's ask the author what's the state of
the result okay so a no no statement is
this right so a for any better there
exists J such that ok so for any better
exists size 0 such that a ok the
distance called the distance a component
of the code I mean you understand that
you re induction doesn't give you this
right only for linear codes you don't
know because you see so you want one
radius that contains a lot of points
when you Center it on any cold war right
so let's say yeah but production but for
my proof I don't need that so yeah okay
I need to think about it maybe my proof
is going to be significantly then then
this part is not needed
and I think that's right i think what
you said was i think it shows that the
weight distribution or distance
distribution would be super binomial
based on this if you have codes better
than amara obviously
anyways but yeah so I mean but for my
prof indeed I think yours is enough ok
so let this makes me more interested in
the second part right so then my
prediction a is incorrect me see any
problem yeah thank you right so I was
spoiled by this proof because they use
this idea
maybe after the top of find Sonia
because so I did easily reduce value
very important oh yes of course yeah I
know of course yes of course if you take
off the radio is half right yeah hey
yeah I'm stupid right right eh the thing
is that this is more radius right so of
course the trade is half most of the
Cold War's our trade is half yeah hey
yeah so that's their existence i 0 which
is small right which is smaller than
something yes yes yeah so yeah I'm
fortune come yeah you can't improve this
ok so let me maybe I really wanted to
advertise the second part more seems
like there is no time
right so so the second part is the
following and so okay so now after we
did this right we have some sphere of
small radius right which is centered at
the Cold War right and contains lots of
points so now let's consider the
following strange problem right so a new
problem Jack many code words and such
that ok such that again and find this to
optimize this quantity which is going to
be again the maximum so it's a it's a
lease decoding problem or multiple
calling but with the twist and the twist
is the following so far every ball I
will explain a very special for every
ball and the cardinality of the R prime
intersect C is bound by L minus 1 okay
but this is not not all balls of radius
R but only that also contains zero
okay so so again so you're basically
studying a multiple packing problem
right but this time around you want to
place the point so that none of them are
contained in the small radius which also
contains zero and it's very strange very
strange problem again there is going to
be some red distance trade off and the
sphere of radius I zero you can see that
of course this can never be less than
half right because just include one
point by the diameter bound you need
half an episode so so there's so this
trade-off is going to be like this okay
I mean of course I don't know this this
curve exactly but the main step is to
show that the a this plot can point so
so this is the main theorem main
contribution in addition to a cali
lineal
okay so pay for every C prime of size of
large size sorry for every sea of large
size this problem has a upper bound of g
1 of X I 0 where what is G 10 kg one of
new expectation average radius
is our ID Bernoulli one-dimensional
right so Heidi Bernoulli new for example
a for l equals 3 what you get is a
something like g one of New is I think
three quarters new- something like half
new cube okay so I'm out of time but the
majority of work of course went into
proving this so this is the i mean i was
going to advertise this idea that
actually in many of these problems when
finding Plotkin point has some
interesting a theory where's yeah at
least right anyways but maybe i'll stop
here but this is different in the list
too and this tree is there an intuition
for desert ah from list of the truth I
don't have the sensation
question